نبدا من حيث انتهيت اذا الاعلام
الاسرائيلي بدا يتحدث عن توغل اسرائيلي في
اقصى المنطقه الجنوبيه لقطاع غزه طبعا
القطاع اليوم يشهد تطورات متسارعه جدا على
طوله من اقصى نقطه في الشمال الى اقصى
نقطه في الجنوب عدنا نتحدث عن اشتباكات
وكاننا في الايام الاولى للحرب
الاسرائيليه على قطاع غزه ولكن سنبدا بال
اعلان الاحدث ايه ال وسائل الاعلام
الاسرائيليه اذا تحدثت عن وجود توغل او ان
الجيش الاسرائيلي سيبدا عمليه توغل من
معبر كرم ابو سالم هذه النقطه ايه الذي
المعبر هذا طبعا يصل قطاع غزه جنوب قطاع
غزه بالاراضي الاسرائيليه بحسب ما سرب
الاعلام الاسرائيلي الجيش الاسرائيلي بدا
يدفع بقوات الى داخل ق قطاع غزه من منطقه
كرم ابو سالم بهدف اقامه ما يسميها الجيش
الاسرائيلي منطقه عازله عند محور
فيلادلفيا داخل اراضي قطاع غزه ابتداء من
النقطه الاولى عند معبر كرم ابو سالم
امتدادا الى
طول المنطقه عرضا طبعا لقطاع غزه وصولا
الى البحر المتوسط تقول يقول الاعلام
الاسرائيلي انها ستكون منطقه عازله وان
الجيش الاسرائيلي سيتمر ما بعد هذه
المنطقه العازله حتى الان طبعا ليس هناك
من تاكيدات رسميه اسرائيليه حول هذه
الخطوه ما سمعناه وما نعرفه ان كتائب
القسام اعلنت انها رصدت صباح اليوم توغلا
لقوات اسرائيليه مؤله عند معبر كرم ابو
سالم وقالت القسام انها استهدفت الاليات
المتوغلة
اصابتها واصابت عدد من الجنود واجبرت هذه
القوات على التراجع الى خارج الخط الحدودي
باتجاه المعبر من الجانب الاسرائيلي هذا
التطور طبعا ليس منفصلا وقد لا يكون
مفاجئا بشكل كامل المنطقه الجنوبيه نذكر
فقط انها ما زالت منطقه اشتباك قويه خاصه
في خان يونس لماذا التحرك الاسرائيلي ان
صحى وتم الاعلان عنه جنوبا لا يعتبر
مفاجئا امس كانت القوات الاسرائيليه قد
اعلنت بشكل غير مباشر او تحدثت عن ان
الجيش الاسرائيلي بصدد الانتقال الى ما
سمتها المرحله الثالثه وهي تتالف من ثلاث
نقاط النقطه الاولى بطبيعه الحال تخفيف
عدد الجنود الموجودين داخل قطاع غزه سحبهم
الى خارج القطاع
وطبعا اتخاذ العمليات شكل جديد ان تكون
العمليات توغلات سريعه والعوده الى
خارج قطاع غزه ولكن النقطه الاهم هي اقامه
منطقه عازله من اقصى نقطه في الشمال شمال
قطاع غزه من اقصى نقطه في الشمال الى اقصى
نقطه في الجنوب وهذه المنطقه العازله
التسريبات تتحدث عن انها تكون بعمق بين
كيلومتر ونصف واثنين
كومتر ما حدث يوم امس هو مساله بالغه
الاهميه لماذا يوم امس هذه النقطه معبر
المنطار او ما كان يسمى معبر المنطار
عندما كان مفتوحا كان معبرا تجاريا شهد
قصفا اسرائيليا مكثفا جدا ومستمرا ادى الى
تهديم مساحات كبيره من المساكن والابنيه
السكنيه المتواجده في في هذه المنطقه التي
هي شرق الشجاعيه بمساواه مدينه غزه قبل
المنطقه الوسطى سبق هذا ايضا مساله مماثله
او تصرفا مماثلا شهدناه عند المناطق
الاعلى في قطاع غزه يوم امس كان بيت حنون
والمنطقه الممتده من اقصى نقطه شمالا الى
المنطار كانت تشهد استهدافات مكثفه وكانت
ايضا تشهد تفجيرات منطقه بيت حانون سمع
فيها يوم امس تفجيرات قويه جدا وايضا ادت
الى دمار مناطق واسعه مناطق سكنيه واسعه
وشاهدنا صور جنود اسرائيليين يفخخ منازل
موجوده عند بيت حنون والمنطقه المجاوره
لبيت حنون ويقومون بنصفها بشكل كامل هذا
يعزز ما يجري الان ان اعلن رسميا اقصى
جنوب القط عند معبر كرم ابو سالم هذا يعني
ان القوات الاسرائيليه بدات تمهد بالنار
على الاقل لاقامه هذه المنطقه العازله
والتموضع داخل هذه المنطقه العازله ل في
حال احتاجت تقول طبعا التسريبات انها
ستقوم بتنفيذ عمليات توغل سريعه وتخرج
وتبقى
خارج الجغرافيا الحاليه لقطاع غزه والتي
بطبيعه الحال ان اقيم المنطقه العازله هنا
الى كامل مساحه قطاع غزه ستكون المساحه
المقطعه بنحو 120 كترا هذه هي المخططات
الاسرائيليه والجانب الامريكي قال يوم امس
انه ربما ان الاوان لتتخذ العمليات
العسكريه شكلا مختلفا ولكن كل ذلك قد
يتوقف على ما يجري ميدانيا اليوم قطاع غزه
كان يشهد اشتباكات ضاريه من من جباليا من
جباليا في الشمال وصولا الى خان يونس في
الجنوب اشتباكات على اكثر من محور وخسائر
كبيره بحسب كتائب القسام وايضا سرايا
القدس وقعت
بالجيش الاسرائيلي